goodnight put my closes ahead I'm Andrew
I'm the dad to a beautiful
eight-year-old named Elaine I live in LA
she's out in Phoenix so every other
weekend I'm driving out there or flying
out there to see her I thought it'd be
cool when I go back out there to do some
things that are a little bit out of the
ordinary we did the makeup challenge
before and I wanted to try something new
so this time I let her style me for a
week I feel like I'm very stylish I'm
pretty trendy I subscribe to GQ you know
I'm in the in-crowd I was a little
nervous letting her style me
she's now has an opinion about clothes I
don't know what that's gonna translate
for me so for the first two days I let
her pick things out of the suitcase for
the next three I let her pick it off of
Amazon I didn't know where this was
gonna go what are we doing day number
one Arizona's a desert it's always hot
so my suitcase is pretty basic some
jeans some t-shirts and that's pretty
much it so she didn't have a ton of
options but I let her kind of go through
and pick it out Lynne really built up
this suspense when she opened my
suitcase but she took her time she
really combed through everything she
laid out shirts to see which one would
go together and things like that that's
fine I'm richer in those two jeans
yes for the first day it was very
straightforward
it was red t-shirt blue jeans I had some
sneakers already packed so it was a
pretty cool outfit she knocked it out
the part I'm on board day one is going
good so far since she did the first
outfit so well we then go to the mall
you excited yeah what story should go to
game time decision I write we'll see
when we get there as we were walking to
the mall I was kind of getting a
temperature of her for the record I want
to know that this little girl who
dresses herself is gonna be the one
styling me for a week so do you think
she has style I don't know
excuse me I don't know do you have that
how do you think you did
you think you did amazing yeah weren't
you the same one who was quitting in the
middle of the story you don't want to go
anymore
it gets boring she's supposed to style
something for me and she had a bug
shopping I shot him okay I was nervous
when she when she showed me that outfit
pic it's not anything I would ever look
at anything I would ever buy but I
didn't want to cheat with the challenge
so I just swallowed my pride and went to
the REC cash register home from the shop
we got a bunch of bags was about to add
me some yellow parachute pants but
luckily they didn't have the size so I
avoided that bullet those are not good
pants those pairs were terrible I think
I did you think your outfits gonna be
really really nice yeah I would say you
pick good clothes think a bunch of
clothes that I picked but he was like
Ari has literally like literally the
same pants the same gains everything
okay day two hey do you think you did
good job day one day two had me a little
nervous the first time she opened my
suitcase
she went right to the jeans the t-shirts
and put it together one two three this
time just one I was not excited not just
one does he some drunk
whatever I know this one I blame myself
for bringing the swim trunks it wasn't
even that hot I didn't even go swimming
I could have just left those at home you
got me there Lane you got me sometimes I
go to Phoenix it's a hundred degrees so
I have swim trunks
sometimes I go to Phoenix it's 60
degrees so I have a hoodie get the
switch okay
she thought it would be a good idea to
put those two things together this
outfit it's great I had so many jeans so
many t-shirts that you skipped through
all of them to get the two extreme
things and put those together and this
is me in the Arizona heat wearing swim
trunks and Van
and the sweatshirt it's uh yeah so on
day two before I left I had to make sure
that she can style the other three days
when I'm not in there and she's not able
to access my suitcase I wanted to keep
it pretty tameable so I boot up Amazon
for I kept her in that 20 to 30 range
and it was very very nerve-wracking what
do you think so far people I don't know
I really does need line after that $20
to be partnering there I was thinking of
all worst-case scenarios where kids know
technology better than we do these days
it was surprising how quickly she picked
up Amazon so I might have shot myself in
the foot there thanks to Amazon Prime
and one-click shopping she was able to
add it to cart deliver it have it sent
to me okay I think I'm done you think
you're done you got it so you have two
days with the clothes yeah all right can
I see it no it's truly amazing that she
can buy a whole outfit on Amazon for 30
bucks I don't know what I'm gonna get in
the mail but I was a sitting on pins and
needles waiting for those shipments to
come in late he's smiling so much so on
to day three I'm wearing the first
outfit that Lynn picked out today
it's a bit bright I was wearing that
outfit that she chose at the mall and
that was the green casual slacks and the
yellow t-shirt with the pink purple
emblem in the middle I guess Lynn was
attracted to this because of the red and
the yellow she really likes colors the
pants didn't really fit me right they
were evader P I think the shirt was long
but it wasn't tight I felt like I was
kind of almost flopping around a little
bit I mean it's not a terrible out it's
different it's a little bit out of my
wheelhouse
we're gonna see what sneakers I can
throw together with this and but I'll
fit together it was definitely
adjustment getting the work I was a
little nervous I have this bright yellow
shirt these puffy green pants and I was
expecting people to drop their coffees
and turn and look but ultimately it was
good the reception to the outfit was
nice I like the outfit I like the shirt
something forever it's a great thing I
talked to one of my co-workers and they
told me I had a youthful energy Timmy
hey Carl
looks like you just
from like concert you know or you're a
camp counselor I just yellow and green
is an interesting pairing but I feel
like the color come was a little camp
counselor and a couple people said they
couldn't tell that I was styled by
eight-year-old so that was a win - did a
great job great job she is a talent and
a rising star all right glowing
recommendations all around so far so
good
so I FaceTime Lane right before she went
to bed and she was just smiling she was
kind of proud of herself and her mom was
in the background trying me in like oh
that's a nice shirt good job limp that
gave me assurance because I felt like
Lynn is doing a good job and maybe I
could get through this challenge okay
day for the first Amazon package came
and this was interesting to say the
least
yep so for the next outfit we have boom
data corns shirt it's pretty dope it
looks like something at eight year old
pick out so I'm not wholly surprised I
think it looks good though it was cute
it was cute she likes unicorns dad a
corn I'll be a daddy unicorn for my
daughter this is fine this is fine she
put it also with these black jeans
they're pretty simple stretch jeans
nothing crazy
it's an all-black outfit and I wear all
black a lot I've a bunch of sneakers the
data corn shirt is a bit cheesy it's
corny but being a dad is corny sometimes
and I play my part when I have to I was
nervous wearing it into the office
because it was one of those kind of
novelty t-shirts every shirt is an excel
type of deal but I wore it proudly what
do you think about my outfit it was
styled by my yoga you look great she did
a good job
did it look like a year old stuff no
like like had you not told me that I
would
yeah so I got through most of the day a
lot of my co-workers kind of gave me the
all and they retreated me awesome and
then I run into Leon destiny you the big
unicorn I guess thanks for that thank
you
I'm not I mean I work out I work out but
I'm not you know so day four wrapped up
without a hitch and the package arrived
for day five and I wasn't ready for wow
we were doing so well
this is why I can't give kids leeway and
you shouldn't teach him how to use the
Amazon yeah so great Joplin should open
that laptop back oh yes a taco costume I
guess after the unicorn shirt she was in
the novelty costume section and somehow
I ended up with a taco it was a curve
ball was not prepared to hit I had to
walk out with a taco and it's funny
because I was actually getting a ride
that day for my roommate on my way to
work hanging out with my favorite my
right-hand man my favorite guy my
roommate Josh he can't even talk he's
just like hi this head in shame so I was
already feeling judged and I haven't
even gotten out my front door yet so I
just knew that this day was gonna be it
was gonna be a long one hey Bros cute
this father-daughter relationship I'm
all for it
fun fact when you have a taco costume
everybody wants to talk to you thinking
back I don't know how we went from like
shirt black jeans to taco costume to
clicks you can change your Amazon life
all right picked up my baby fresh up out
of school hey feeling good what did you
think about the outfits the taco one was
amazing because it was very very selling
you know me out excelling in the data
corn one that was just amazing it's sad
cause you know cramming like how could
you not how could you not I would
definitely recommend that every parent
let's take a style um at least once you
might find some new combinations they
might add some new color or you might
end up in a costume
who knows dad's come in all shapes and
sizes we do a lot of crazy things if my
new way of connecting is me looking like
an idiot for my daughter I'm here for
I'll do it again I'll sign up a hundred
percent of the time
love you Lane
[Music]
I have an idea baby you could stop me
for a week
if I value for a week huh makeup
included